réponse est 'oui' week end sur la terre
car sur quoi sur mon look
je me suis habillé comme un vendeur de
roses
bonsoir à tous merci la planète nous
touche pas à mon poste chez vous ne
parlez pas de ma chemise bicolore ça y
est ça si on la brûle et on a fait une
très bonne soirée l'air chiant boom
version des tentures maître chien là oui
oui j'ai fait un petit pot de soudure
avant de venir à l'émission et au stand
de tir ya deux minutes y'a beaucoup de
vos looks rock mais je le connais c'est
dégueulasse c'est le seul animateur télé
il s'habille comme toi quand tu regarde
la télé que la tenue de brad pitt dans
thelma et louise cesse à terme elle oui
oui ça tourne beaucoup pendant les
vacances ya beaucoup de turn over
je ne vous cache pas qu'est ce que c'est
que cette tenue d'un rideau vous n'avez
plus c'est comme lenny kravitz mais ont
des gueules voilà mais non mais lui ça
fait tout de suite beau gosse moi ça
fait dégueulasse et s'imagine si besoin
de laurent delahousse et tessa bonsoir à
tous merci
alors les titres du journal
et regardez qui nous a rejoint thierry
moreau et oui on s'est croisés sur tp ne
fait pas longtemps on s'est croisé n'a
pas été longtemps sans que j'en ai même
plateau ah oui vous êtes parti en 2010
est absolument le mois de mai 2010 de
beats début de mai 2010 est un petit mot
pour caractériser celle d'un seul mot un
seul mot fou mais au sens sympa du terme
fou fou dans tous les sens en dehors de
en vue lors de la de la planète ça il
est voilà c'est fait il est pas comme
nous